[Music]
to me terrorists means a person who
incites terror it's very simple I think
that I think that Isis fighters are
terrorists just as much as I believe
that weis just as much as I believe that
white mass shooters are terrorists
however in however in the media's
definition of terrorism the word is only
ever applied when it comes to a brown
person or a person of the Muslim faith
and a person is only ever identified for
their religion when it comes to a
terrorist attack if they happen to be
Muslim and when we do that inevitably we
are linking terrorism with Islam and
Islam with terrorism and we make this
common assumption that all Muslims are
terrorists or the old terrorists are
Muslim and that of course is an
impossible generalization to make when
you put into perspective that there are
1.8 billion Muslims on the planet it is
impossible to say that they're all
terrorists and it's actually a very
dehumanizing thing to try to categorize
them in that way to put that into
context there are 2.2 billion Christians
in the world so you have 2.2 billion
Christians and 1.8 billion Muslims so
just as ridiculous it would be to make
one assumption or one generalization
about the entire Christian population
that's just as ridiculous as it would be
to make that assumption about the entire
Muslim people and yet when you ask a
common American on the street what they
think of when they hear the word
terrorist of course the first image that
comes to mind will be of the
stereotypical person of Muslim faith and
of course that is extremely dangerous
you know like there was a situation a
couple of years ago that is still a
tremendous source of anxiety from Muslim
woman today and that was when a Hindu
man was pushed off of the platform on
the subway onto the tracks of an
oncoming train and was killed and the
woman that did so said that she's hated
Muslims
ever since 9/11 happened so let's think
about that for a second this woman hated
all 1.8 billion Muslims in the world
because 9/11 took place and then her her
stereotypical image of what Muslims look
like you know having
on skin being dark in that she ended up
pushing a Hindu man a man of a
completely different faith to his death
that's how bad racism is that's how it
that's how this surfaces in our everyday
lives just through media representation
alone through the way that we depict
Muslims on TV or minorities in general
we're literally engineering our reality
and it's us that have to bear the burden
of that we're the ones that that
directly impacts and it's very unfair
for us to try to implicate an entire
people for individual actions I think
it's crucial for us to talk about
terrorism in all of its forms and not
confine it to this frame of just being
in the context of radical Islam or the
war on terror that's a huge disservice
and you know especially when you look at
the statistics that many times more
people have died on American soil since
2001 due to mass shootings then two
terrorist attacks it really makes you
wonder where our attention is really
being placed right now and especially
because you know Donald Trump for
example had no problem saying that we
need to ban all Muslim immigration
because of terrorism because of like
this and that meanwhile if we use the
same logic then we should be able to say
that we want to ban all white men from
the country because they make up the
majority of mass shooters that are
spilling all this blood on our soil but
no one ever talks about that however it
seems like it's common sense when it's
applied just to Muslims but that's just
how ridiculous it is this discussion
about a registry for Muslims has been
something that I've had tremendous
difficulty wrapping my head around just
because of how ludicrous it is and just
how blatantly obvious it is that it's
wrong that seems to just like fly over
people's heads and it has made me try to
understand how people can think that
this is okay historically it's only ever
been in moments of tremendous fear like
this that we have allowed our government
to oppress its own citizens or to rob
people of their rights or to impose on
their civil rights that they're entitled
to constitutionally and that's always
empowered by a social attitude of
acceptance not even just acceptance but
maybe
complete apathy of people not caring how
that impacts not just our fellow
Americans other human beings but also
just what that means for us as a country
of what we stand for it's quite simple
to understand why a Muslim registry is
wrong any type of targeting of a person
for their religion for the color of
their skin for the sexual orientation
their gender their background is wrong
and for us to create a registry of
people solely because of their religion
that literally is exactly identical to
Nazi Germany that's exactly how the
Holocaust started and the thing is ever
since the Holocaust we as humanity have
constantly asked ourselves how could we
have allowed something like that to
happen how did people in Europe allow
millions of people get burnt to their
death and not say anything and just be
completely okay with that taking place
and now with what's taking place in
America and and seeing the attitudes
that people have towards these
terrifying policy suggestions just makes
it very obvious how something like that
can happen and how it can easily repeat
itself in history it's through complete
apathy through allowing through
empowering that type of ignorance and
yeah knowing that we don't understand
about other people and not caring about
seeking that understanding or you know
backing policies that impact them or
target them specifically without having
any information about them or any type
of awareness of what that policy means
to us on a national level and I think
that that's kind of a reality that has
been exploited by our politicians today
you know they have written on this
misunderstanding and this ignorant in
order to empower their own platforms and
those platforms have come on the backs
of people that are already marginalized
and that are already bearing the brunt
of all this hateful discrimination and
and stereotyping that's been taking
place and I think that we have to put a
stop to it if we don't stand up and
recognize what's taking place right now
then it's a slippery slope and it
honestly is very terrifying to imagine
where else it could lead because a year
ago I never
imagine that we would even be
entertaining a conversation about a
Muslim registry and now it's actually
something that's being considered as a
real policy and that too means it's just
obscene
[Music]